hey this is presh talwalkar
the puzzle begins with the following
information
you are given a circle and a diameter a
b of the circle
you are also given a point c that's on
the circle
the challenge is to construct
cd
that's perpendicular to a b
but there's a challenging part of this
puzzle you are only allowed to use a
straight edge as the tool
you are not allowed to use a compass
this problem was asked by russian prime
minister mish houston to students who
are approximately 17 to 18 years old
it was posted on icm
2022 and i saw it via alex belos's
column on the guardian
this is an amazing geometric puzzle and
i'll admit i wasn't able to solve it but
the answer is so remarkable that i
wanted to share it with all of you
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so here's the remarkable construction
first we will connect bc and ca
then angle bca is an inscribed angle in
a semi-circle which means angle bca is a
90 degree right angle
now let's take some other point f along
this same semicircle
we will connect af and fb
by the same logic angle afb is an
inscribed angle in a semi-circle so it
is a 90 degree right angle
from here
extend a f and bc
to form a point g
now we have a triangle
a g b
in this triangle
ac is an altitude upon b g
and b f is an altitude upon a g
the point at which they intersect is h
and that's the orthocenter of the
triangle abg
an interesting property of the
orthocenter is it's actually the unique
point where all three altitudes of the
triangle meet
therefore g h will be along the altitude
of a b
so we know that if we extend g h to the
side a b it will meet the side at a
right angle
now from here let's label this point p
where g h extends to intersect with the
circle
we'll now clean up this construction a
little bit
let's get rid of this triangle
and from there let's get rid of some
other things and we'll label the point q
along this circle
so q and p are exactly reflected points
about the diameter a b
let's now get rid of these right
triangles
so from here
we've already reflected the point q
across the diameter to the point p
we similarly want to reflect the point c
across the diameter a b so how do we do
that
we will connect qc and extend the
diameter a b until they meet at a point
r
now we'll connect r and p
by symmetry
the point at which r p intersects a
circle we'll label this s will exactly
be the point c reflected about the
diameter a b
we then will connect cs
because c and s are reflected points
about the diameter a b
they will meet the diameter at the point
d
and that will be at a right angle and
thus we have constructed cd that's
perpendicular to a b and all we've used
is a straight edge and some interesting
geometry concepts
what an amazing construction
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you